in june of 1985 mark johnson and his
wife of 10 years
sophie were on vacation in myrtle beach
having a great time
while they relaxed on the sand sophie
decided to take a picture of her husband
for their scrapbook
so she pulled out the polaroid super
color 645 that she'd bought specifically
for the trip
she pressed the button waiting for the
picture to print
pulled it out and shook it what she
expected to see was a shot of mark
lying on his beach towel what she got
was a picture of her husband
in the arms of his secretary they say
that a picture speaks a thousand words
but this particular camera takes
pictures that are worth
even more than that when developed the
pictures taken with this normal looking
polaroid camera reveal the innermost
desires of the person being photographed
welcome to the story of scp-978
the desire camera the main reason the
foundation keeps scp-970
under wraps is due to its use as an easy
form of blackmail
all anyone with access to the camera
would have to do is snap a few covert
photos
and they'd have instant dirt on the
world's most powerful people
to further stop this camera from falling
into the wrong hands
the containment guidelines strictly
forbid the use of the camera for
anything other than simple documentation
and all uses of it must be thoroughly
logged and checked
so now that you know what the camera
does
it's time to look at what kinds of
strange and mysterious photos it's taken
after all who doesn't want a chance to
gain insight into the minds of the
foundation's most famous
and dangerous inmates first to serve as
a control the team took a photo of a
blue
office chair no change was recorded
proving that the camera didn't work on
non-anomalous inanimate objects
some of the earliest tests of the camera
were the photos that the research team
took of each other
one by one the doctors and their
assistants were photographed in neutral
poses
smiling as if for a completely normal
photo
then they waited while the photos
developed like normal polaroids
most of the research team had minimal
changes in their photos
one was shown slouched in his chair
drinking from a flask
one was shown in her civilian clothes
getting ready to go home from work
one doctor was in the exact same pose
but with a different colored tie on
the last assistant photographed however
had their picture come out
wildly different than how they were
posed their desire revealed by the
camera was so
shocking that it had to be redacted and
the assistant was placed on temporary
psychiatric leave following this first
successful test
the doctor in charge of the project
ordered a second round of tests to be
conducted
this time on a series of d-class
personnel a picture of one d-class who
was photographed while eating in the
cafeteria showed up as scuba diving on
vacation with his wife and child
he was allowed to keep the picture
afterwards another had a similar result
he was photographed in a neutral pose
like the members of the research team
had been
and when the picture developed the
d-class was seen holding a smiling baby
whom he identified as his one-year-old
daughter after that
the results of the scp-978 test started
to get a little
well weird a notoriously twisted d-class
known as 7294 was photographed in his
cell
and when the polaroid developed he was
in the same cell playing a cello made
out of a dismembered mannequin
d-217-017 was a late-stage victim of
scp-272 a virus that turns organic
matter into metal
you would assume that her innermost
desire would be to be cured of her
disease
but when she was photographed in her
cell the resulting polaroid showed her
completely made of metal
kneeling and praying at the base of a
black obelisk
one d-class who had been rendered
comatose and was on life support
was photographed in their hospital room
their picture showed them as only a limp
deflated skin in their photo the
photograph of another d-class
who had become increasingly listless and
apathetic since their integration
into the d-class program resulted in a
picture that was exactly the same as
they appeared in reality
except the light in their cell was
slightly dimmer intrigued by these
results
the research team wanted to see how the
camera would react to scp-148
a type of metal that blocks the psychic
properties of other scps
a helmet was made from the material and
placed on a d-class who was given an
adult magazine to read while his photo
was taken
when the photo was developed it was
extremely blurry
upon close analysis the figure of the
d-class reading the magazine could still
be made out
and around him the faint images of
several nude people could be seen
the research team wanted to see if the
results were the same when the camera
was used on animals
photos of the lab mice and rabbits
showed them eating or mating in their
respective polaroids
a zebra finch was shown escaping its
cage while a guard dog and its handler
were shown playing fetch in the park
when cockroaches were photographed there
was no difference visible between the
picture
and reality but the most exciting test
results came when the camera was
tested on other scps for a few of the
scps tested
there was no visible difference between
the picture and reality
this was the case for scp-173 the
sculpture
scp-343 nicknamed god scp-014
an immortal man who is over time being
turned into concrete
and scp-063 the world's best toothbrush
when scp-035 better known as the
possessive mask was photographed in its
glass case
the picture showed an unidentified
individual wearing the mask
sitting on a throne and surrounded by
three masked corpses
the team took a picture of scp-043
a haunted copy of the white album that
was being interrogated while on a
turntable
in the picture the album was being
returned to its sleeve
they then photographed scp-049 the
plague doctor
standing in his cell in the picture the
plague doctor is hugging an unidentified
small
child and surrounded by instances of
scp-049-2
when they took a picture of scp-050 a
mischievous statue of a monkey reading a
book
the result was predictably playful given
that scp's history of pulling pranks
the photo that came out of the camera
showed the camera itself
with another picture of itself coming
out of the developing slot
microscopic analysis revealed that this
recursive photography kept going
until the cameras and the pictures of
the other cameras were too
small to see the team next photographed
scp-053
the young girl and the photo was taken
as the young girl was drawing with
crayons in her cell
in the picture she was riding through a
sunny field on the back of her friend
scp-682 scp-053
and scp-682 were even wearing matching
bows
dresses and pink nail polish when they
took a picture of scp-096 the shy guy
though
the picture showed scp-096's cell with
nothing in it
scp-085 the living 2d sketch known as
cassie
was photographed tinkering with a drawn
car in the developed photo
cassie was engaged in the same activity
but both she
and the car were now three-dimensional
the team took a photo of scp-106 the old
man
emerging from a wall within his cell
when the photo developed
it showed the old man roaming a wheat
field near an old farmhouse
from the porch of the farmhouse an older
woman is greeting scp-106 with
open arms they also took a photo of
scp-168
a sentient calculator sitting on a table
in its containment cell
in the picture a teenage boy is seen
doing complex math homework using the
calculator
next to him on the table are thick
textbooks with titles like
complicated math difficult math and math
you need your calculator for
the photo of scp-261 a vending machine
that dispenses snack products from
alternate universes
showed the scp in its usual hallway
almost
completely buried in coins scp-507
an otherwise normal man who unwillingly
teleports between dimensions
was photographed while eating in the
cafeteria the developed picture
showed him dressed as a foundation
researcher talking to other researchers
when scp-682 was photographed floating
in its containment tank
the resulting picture showed the scp
surrounded by the corpses of all of the
foundation staff
and mauling the person who had taken the
photo a researcher's note accompanying
this photo reads
well that was predictable yes yes it was
just for the fun of it the team also
tested the camera's effects on a few
other foundation personnel
they took a photo of dr bright while he
was arguing with dr clough
the picture that came out showed a
tombstone engraved with the words
jack bright resting at last the team
also took a photo of dr
cleff as he stormed out in a huff
following the argument
given that clap's face cannot be
photographed they were curious as to
what the results would be
the picture showed little difference
compared to reality save for the fact
that clef's head was replaced by an
image of a hand making a rude gesture
upon closer examination of the photo the
team also realized that there was a
young girl in the background
who strangely had cloven hooves instead
of
feet a young scp-166 perhaps
the team then took a photo of dr fisher
holding his pet hamster
contrary to expectations the picture
revealed not dr fisher's desires
but the hamsters showing the hamster
sleeping peacefully in its cage
with dr fisher nowhere to be seen as you
can see from these test logs
the effects of the camera are well
inconsistent
with some photos showing very immediate
simple whims
another showing the subject's deepest
and most secret desires
while the researchers working with
scp-978 seemed like they had a lot of
fun getting to peek into the minds of
all their co-workers
and test subjects there's no telling
what kind of pandemonium could be
unleashed of someone on the outside ever
got a chance to use it
thankfully the camera which has been
classified as safe for obvious reasons
is kept securely in security locker hj12
at site-17
which means none of us have to worry
about our own pictures taken
by the desire camera leaking out but if
someone did get the camera out and took
your picture
what do you think they'd see now go
check out scp-001
which is the real zero zero one and
scp-05
the anti-meme for more of the strangest
stories from the scp foundation